This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In July 1798, an English poet visited the countryside on the banks of the river Y. On seeing the natural beauty of the area, William Wordsworth composed a poem. It's titled, Lines Written a Few Miles Above Tintanabi. At one point, he describes the effect of the landscape on his psychological state. He writes, and the round ocean and the living air, and the blue sky and in the mind of man, a motion and a spirit that impels all thinking things, all objects of all thought, and rolls through all things.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。1798年7月，一位英国诗人来到Y河畔的乡村。威廉·华兹华斯看到当地的自然美景后，创作了一首诗。诗的题目是《丁登寺几里上方行军所作》。在其中一段，他描述了风景对他的心理状态的影响。他写道：那圆形的海洋，充满生机的空气，蔚蓝的天空，以及人类的心灵中，存在着一种运动和精神，它驱使着所有有思想的事物、一切思想的客体，并在万物中流转。
Now the romantic poets were sometimes given to literary excess. They felt things deeply and they wrote effusively. But more than two centuries after Wordsworth composed his poem, some scientists today are asking an unusual question. Would the Romantics on to something? This week on Hidden Brain, in the final episode of our series, Happiness 2.0, we look at what happens when we stop, really stop, to of the central challenges and human behavior has been the problem of suffering. We all have aches and ailments, setbacks at work, and conflicts in personal relationships.
浪漫主义诗人有时会有过度文学化的倾向。他们感受深沉，笔端奔放。但在华兹华斯创作这首诗两个多世纪后，如今的一些科学家提出了一个不同寻常的问题：浪漫主义者是否说中了一些道理？本周的《隐藏的大脑》迎来“幸福2.0”系列节目的最后一集，我们将探讨当我们停下脚步——真正停下脚步——时会发生什么。人类行为的核心挑战之一一直是痛苦问题。我们都有病痛和不适、工作中的挫折，以及人际关系中的冲突。
Many years ago, the psychologist Dacor Kelt, found himself in a world of suffering. He was in his early thirties and had just moved from California to Wisconsin. What happened to me, Shankar, is I lived a life largely in California, in the hills, in the mountains, in the oceans, in the culture, and so forth. And I went 2,000 miles away, and it was flat, and there were were storms and there was snow and people rooted for the packers and they ate brought worst and you know there was no Mexican food and and the weather and the cold the cold rattled me I felt like Camus stranger in a way like I am in a strange land that I just physically temperature wise climate wise people wise I felt like a fish out of water,
许多年前，心理学家达卡·凯尔特纳发现自己置身于一个充满痛苦的世界。他当时三十出头，刚从加利福尼亚搬到威斯康星州。尚卡尔，我当时的经历是，我的大部分生活都在加利福尼亚度过，那里有群山、大山、海洋、文化等等。而我搬到了2000英里之外，那里地势平坦，有风暴，有雪，人们支持包装工队，吃着小香肠，你知道的，那里没有墨西哥菜，而且天气很冷，那股寒冷让我感到震撼。我感觉自己就像加缪笔下的局外人，仿佛身处异国他乡。无论是生理上、温度上、气候上还是人际上，我都觉得自己像离水的鱼，
even though I look like somebody from Wisconsin, I'm, you know, Northern European heritage. Daccar, who was just starting his career as a professor, started to experience extreme bouts of anxiety. I come from a family on my mom's side that has a lot of anxiety and I started to have profound panic attacks really beginning with the day that I departed to drive across the country to Wisconsin. I had probably, I would say, 70 or 80 a year, really technical or full-blown panic attacks, when I was teaching, when I would go see a movie to try to relax when I would fly on an airplane to go to a conference,
尽管我看起来像是威斯康星州本地人，你知道的，我是北欧血统。达卡当时刚开始他的教授生涯，开始经历极度的焦虑。我母亲家族那边有很多人都有焦虑症，我开始出现严重的惊恐发作，真的就从我开车横跨美洲前往威斯康星州的那天开始。我每年大概会发作70到80次，是非常技术性或完全爆发的惊恐发作，当我在授课时，当我去看电影试图放松时，当我坐飞机去参加会议时，
when I would hear from a colleague, and it really caught me off guard, Chunker, like, wow, why am I feeling so estranged and anxious all the time. Everything around Dacca seemed to remind him of his isolation. Everywhere he went, he experienced vulnerability. He felt that his life was about to end. My God, you know, for those people out in the audience who've had real panic attacks, they are spectacular and they hit you and you literally the brain says you're dying and your body is telling you you Dacker Keltner are dying and you're about to die right here. It felt really solitary.
当我听到同事的消息时，这真的让我措手不及，尚卡尔，就像，哇，为什么我一直感到如此疏离和焦虑。在达卡周围，一切似乎都在提醒他自己的孤立。无论他走到哪里，他都体验到脆弱感。他觉得自己的生活即将结束。天哪，你知道的，对于台下那些经历过真正惊恐发作的人来说，它们是惊天动地的，它们袭击了你，你的大脑字面意思是你在消亡，你的身体在告诉你，达卡·凯尔特纳，你正在消亡，你马上就要死在这里了。这种感觉真的很孤独。
Now remember there was this book about weird stories from Wisconsin about how anxious people ended up dying in Wisconsin. Because they would go out and start tilling the earth on their farm at two in the morning, you know, and everything was frozen and the guy froze to death. And I was like, this is going to happen to me. And it was happening to me. Dacquard had moved across the country to join the University of Wisconsin. But his work provided no solace. I was getting rejected for grants.
现在回想起来，当时有一本关于威斯康星州离奇故事的书，讲的是焦虑的人如何在威斯康星州惨死。因为他们会在凌晨两点跑出去在农场的土地上耕作，你知道的，当时一切都冻结了，那个人被冻死了。我想：这也会发生在我身上。而这确实正在发生。达卡跨越大半个美国来到威斯康星大学任教。但他的工作并没有提供任何慰藉。我的基金申请被拒绝了。
Papers were getting rejected. There was a conference on the social nature of emotion, which is what I was writing about and defined my career on. I got rejected from. I started a dream about people broadcasting all the rejections of my papers and ideas and the like, you know, I got a very mediocre to bad mid-career review. It was a real struggle to be quite honest in a lot of suffering. So, like many of us who've been through something similar, you tried to do a number of things
论文被退稿。有一场关于情感社会本质的会议，这正是我一直在写并以此定义我的职业生涯的领域。我的申请被拒了。我开始做噩梦，梦见人们到处广播我被退稿的论文和想法等等，你知道的，我的职业生涯中期评估结果非常平庸甚至很差。老实说，那是一场真正的挣扎，伴随着许多痛苦。所以，就像许多经历过类似事情的我们一样，你试图做很多事情
to make yourself feel better. At one point, you and some fellow academics banded together to form a basketball team. Tell me about that. Why did you do that and how did it go? We formed this team that we named the Laughing Amygdala. Because the Amygdala was all the rage at the time. It was Joe Ladoo, the Amygdala, the threat center, et cetera. And what was great aboutadoo, the Amigula, the Threat Center, et cetera. And what was great about our team, Shanker, is we are all professors and three graduate
来让自己感觉好一点。有一次，你和一些同行学者联合起来组建了一支篮球队。跟我聊聊这个吧。你为什么要这么做，结果怎么样？我们组建了这支球队，取名为“大笑的杏仁核”。因为当时杏仁核风靡一时。那是乔·勒杜、杏仁核、威胁中心等等。关于我们的球队最棒的地方在于，尚卡尔，我们全都是教授和三名研究生，
students. And we had this really unlikely team, and we won championships on the campus. We beat the football team, the fraternities, and people were just stunned. And so it was this magical run, and you know, Shankar, from the solitary life of 3 a.m., I would go to the gym and play, and basketball is five people flowing in motion in a sense of, you know, just we're all connected doing things together. And when I'd walked to the gym, it felt like a sanctuary that I would go there and leave behind the anxiety.
我们组成了这支极其不可思议的球队，并且赢得了校园里的冠军。我们击败了橄榄球队、兄弟会，人们都惊呆了。所以这是一段神奇的经历，你知道的，尚卡尔，从凌晨3点孤独的生活中，我会去体育馆打球。篮球运动是五个人在运动中流动，有一种……你知道的，我们紧密相连、共同做事的默契。当我走向体育馆时，那里就像一个避难所，我走到那里，就能把焦虑抛在脑后。
I want to play a clip of Musicia Dacker. It's from Raw Power, the 1973 album by Iggy Pop and the studios. Doca, what memories does this music hold for you? Shankar, one of the, I think one of the deepest mysteries in science right now in the social sciences is why does music speak to us? And why does it speak to our soul? And when I was in Madison, Wisconsin, I was really, you know, fighting and with anxiety and, you know, trying to find my way in life. And at that time, I'd probably seen you to be Iggy Pop kind of a godfather of punk rock
我想播放一段音乐家达卡的剪辑。这是伊基·波普和工作室1973年的专辑《原始力量》中的音乐。达卡，这段音乐对你来说有什么样的回忆？尚卡尔，我认为目前社会科学中最深奥的谜团之一，就是为什么音乐能触动我们？为什么它能触动我们的心灵？当我在威斯康星州麦迪逊市时，我真的，你知道的，在与焦虑作斗争，在寻找人生的方向。在那个时候，我大概看过伊基·波普——朋克摇滚的教父级人物——
about six to eight times and he played, I think it was in Milwaukee and I took some friends to the show and it was just like basketball. Like I was leaving behind the heat of anxiety of my academic life, my young career. And I go to the show and I get up close and we're in this throbbing mosh pit that's scientist now study and he comes out and he sings all his great songs, you know,
大约六到八次。他演出，我想是在密尔沃基，我带了一些朋友去看演出，这感觉就像打篮球一样。就像我把学术生活、年轻职业生涯中焦虑的热度抛在了脑后。我去观看演出，走得很近，身处那个科学家如今仍在研究的喧嚣人潮中，他走出来，演唱他所有伟大的歌曲，你知道的，
raw power, you know, less for life and passenger. I know them. I'm singing. You know, at one point he dives out into their crowd and I'm right there and I hold him you know and he's allopped on all of our hands and Shankar I touch his skin and and his skin feels like God you know I'm just like I can't believe I'm holding you in the Iggy Pop's bicep. So I when I leave in Iggy Pop, I'm drenched in sweat. I don't know who I am. I'm embracing strangers.
《原始力量》、《生而渴望》和《乘客》。我都懂。我跟着唱。你知道的，有一次他纵身跃入人群中，我就在那里，我托住了他，你知道的，他躺在我们所有人的手上。尚卡尔，我触摸到了他的皮肤，他的皮肤感觉就像神一样，你知道的，我当时想：我简直不敢相信我托住了伊基·波普的二头肌。所以当我离开伊基·波普的演出现场时，我浑身湿透。我不知道我是谁。我拥抱陌生人。
And I feel alive and pure. So I go back to Wisconsin. And I look at his CD and it says, if you feel like writing me, drop me a line. Here's my address. So I write him. You know, and I tell him about all my stories, you know, seeing him and how it may, importantly, he's been to me as a young professor, handling my
我感到充满活力和纯粹。于是我回到威斯康星州。我看着他的CD，上面写着：“如果你想写信给我，就给我留个便条。这是我的地址。”所以我写信给他。你知道的，我告诉他我的所有故事，你知道的看他的演出，以及作为一个年轻教授面对挣扎时，他是多么重要地支持了我。
struggles. Six months later, I get a letter back in this little shaky scroll. And it's like, he says, thanks for yours. All of your stories. I really appreciate them. Good luck getting access to the young skulls at UW. I dig teachers, Iggy Pop. And I'm getting goosebumps talking about this now. I held the letter and I'm like, my life's okay. I have courage and strength. And when I'd bounce up stage on the stage and teach my 300 students,
六个月后，我收到了一封回信，上面是颤抖的字迹。上面写着：“谢谢你的来信。你所有的故事。我真的很感激。祝你在威斯康星大学接触到那些年轻的头脑时好运。我懂老师们。——伊基·波普。”现在谈起这个我都起鸡皮疙瘩。我拿着这封信想：我的生活没问题。我有勇气和力量。当我昂首挺胸走上讲台给300名学生上课时，
getting my mediocre reviews and making mistakes here and there, I felt more strong in a life. You were touched by the hand of God here, Dacker., you and your wife were outside watching a summer storm approach. Tornado warnings were going off. Describe for me what was happening and tell me what you both did next. My wife, Molly Grupens, the Afro-Cisco, we both were adapting to the weather and the climate and the landscape. And this storm starts rolling in
尽管收到了平庸的评价，在这里那里犯错，我感到生活变得更坚强了。达卡，你在这里感受到了上帝之手。你和妻子在室外看着一场夏日风暴逼近。龙卷风警报正在拉响。请向我描述当时发生了什么，并告诉我你们接下来做了什么。我和妻子莫莉·格鲁彭斯，他是旧金山人，我们俩都在适应这里的天气、气候和风景。这场风暴开始席卷而来，
and you could see it from afar and those clouds looked horrifying and they looked strong and dangerous. And then there was some kind of warning that said get in your basement, a tornado warning. And I think tornadoes did land that day. And for whatever reason, we said, let's feel it. Let's get out in the storm. Let's see what the mystery is.
你可以从远处看到它，那些云看起来非常可怕，它们看起来强壮而危险。然后某种警报响起，说快去地下室，那是龙卷风警报。我想那天真的有龙卷风着陆了。出于某种原因，我们说：去感受一下吧。让我们走到风暴中去。看看这个谜团究竟是什么。
And let's just, you know, we couldn't really explain it, but we sat out on our swing on our front porch. As this wild storm ripped through, you know, Madison for half an hour or whatever it was, and rain, and lightning, and massive winds. And again, it felt, I just felt so alive and free of the shackles of my anxiety at the time. So it was a striking experience.
让我们……你知道的，我们无法真正解释它，但当这场狂野的风暴在麦迪逊肆虐了半小时左右时，我们坐在前廊的秋千上，伴随着雨水、闪电和狂风。再次，这种感觉，我感到如此充满活力，摆脱了当时焦虑的枷锁。所以这是一次震撼的体验。
So these all seem like very different experiences, enjoying teamwork in a basketball game, being part of a crowd at a music concert, watching a storm approach. Is there a common thread that connects these experiences, Taker? You know, it was really interesting, Shankar, because I was really struggling in these four years, and I, you know, I was chronically anxious, tons of panic attacks, struggling career-wise, really feeling away from home, and I didn't know how to find happiness, which has been a life's puzzle for me in many ways. And I think what I was doing in these experiences
所以这些听起来像是非常不同的体验，在篮球比赛中享受团队合作，在音乐会上成为人群的一部分，看着风暴逼近。达卡，有没有一条共同的线索将这些体验联系在一起？你知道的，这真的很有趣，尚卡尔，因为我在那四年里一直在苦苦挣扎，而且我，你知道的，我长期焦虑，有大量的惊恐发作，职业生涯举步维艰，真的感觉远离家乡，我不知道如何寻找幸福，这在许多方面一直是我人生的谜题。我想我在这些经历中所做的是
is I was getting outside of myself on the basketball court. It's just the motion and the physicality and you're playing with five people. I was losing myself. And I lost myself right up front like in a mosh pit near seeing Iggy Pop and feeling the music. And I lost myself in the storm. I was just like, I was throwing myself into things where I could lose myself.
我跳出了自我。在篮球场上。这只是一种运动和身体感，你和五个人一起玩。我在忘我。我在观看伊基·波普演出时那种靠近舞台的狂热人群中忘我，感受着音乐。我在风暴中忘我。我就像，我把自己投入到那些能让我忘我的事情中去。
LegWilliam Woodsworth two centuries ago, Dakar had begun to discover ways out of his narrow preoccupations. When we come back, the connections between these different experiences and the science behind a mind-expanding emotion. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. University of California, Berkeley Psychologist, Dackar Keltner studies what he calls pro-social emotions, feelings like love, compassion, and gratitude. Earlier in his life, he tried to get himself through a difficult time by immersing himself
正如两个世纪前的威廉·华兹华斯一样，达卡已经开始探索摆脱狭隘执念的方法。稍后我们将探讨这些不同体验之间的联系，以及拓展心灵的情感背后的科学。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。加州大学伯克利分校心理学家达卡·凯尔特纳研究他所谓的亲社会情感，比如爱、同情和感恩等感觉。在他早期的生活中，他通过让自己沉浸在
in sports, in music, and in the beauties of the natural world. In time, he realized there was a common connection between these activities. They all activated a feeling of being awestruck. Now at the University of California Berkeley, D'Akkore spent years studying the science of all. D'Akkore, I want to talk about your scientific explorations of awe, but so much of your intellectual journey starts with your personal journey. Both your parents were attuned to the world of art. Can you tell me about them? Yeah, you know, it's funny. I really lived a life that
体育、音乐和自然世界的美景中，来度过一段艰难的时期。渐渐地，他意识到这些活动之间有一个共同的联系。它们都激活了一种敬畏感。现在，在加州大学伯克利分校，达卡花了多年时间研究敬畏科学。达卡，我想谈谈你对敬畏的科学探索，但你的许多智识探索都始于你的个人旅程。你的父母都对艺术世界很敏感。能跟我讲讲他们吗？是的，你知道的，很有趣。我的生活在某种程度上，
really is in some sense from my first moments of being born in Mexico. A life as an experiment in all, formative years in Laurel Canyon, California in the late 60s, so much music going on, Joni Mitchell the doors. My dad was a painter and he loved awe-inspiring, horrifying work, Goya, Velasquez, Francis Bacon and others, right? Just as a kid, I was just seeing images all the time. And then my mom loved awe in literature and it was getting her PhD eventually taught at Cal State Sacramento and loved, you know loved Virginia Woolf and her awesome portrayals of the mind. And the romanticism and wordsworth and Blake, and I would hear quotes of Blake, and she
从我在墨西哥出生的第一刻起，就是一个关于敬畏的实验。我在60年代末的加利福尼亚州劳雷尔峡谷度过了成长岁数，那里有如此多的音乐，琼尼·米切尔、多门乐队。我父亲是一名画家，他喜欢那些令人敬畏、令人震撼的作品，戈雅、委拉斯开兹、弗朗西斯·培根等人，对吧？作为一个孩子，我一直在看这些图像。然后我母亲热爱文学中的敬畏，她最终在萨克拉门托加州州立大学获得了博士学位并任教，热爱、你知道的，热爱弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫及其对心灵令人敬畏的描绘。还有浪漫主义、华兹华斯和布莱克，我会听到布莱克的名言，她
told me about the prelude of wordsworth and also DH Lawrence and others. And so my parents were pointing me at an early age from like five and six. Here are quotes about awe. Here's our paintings of awe. Here is music. You know, I remember listening to Sergeant Pepper's when it came out, the Beatles, together as a family. Like, life's about awe.
跟我讲过华兹华斯的《序曲》以及D·H·劳伦斯等人。所以我的父母从我很小的时候（比如五六岁）就开始引导我。这里是关于敬畏的名言。这里是关于敬畏的画作。这里是音乐。你知道的，我记得我们全家一起听过甲壳虫乐队发行的《佩珀军士寂寞之心俱乐部乐队》。人生就是关于敬畏的。
Go do it. Walk up, fell out of bed, dragged to comb across my head, found the way downstairs and drank a cup I understand that your family moved to a rural community in the foothills of the Sierra's and you and your brother, Ralph, spent many days roaming outside in nature. You know, it was incredible. My parents, you know, was 1970, my mom had just gotten this job at Cal State Sacramento, as an English professor teaching romanticism and the like.
去体验吧。从床上爬起来，拖着梳子梳过头发，找到下楼的路，喝了一杯……我听说你的搬家到了内华达山脉山麓的一个乡村社区，你和你的弟弟拉尔夫在野外自然中度过了许多天。你知道的，这太不可思议了。我的父母，你知道的，那是1970年，我母亲刚在萨克拉门托加州州立大学得到了这份工作，担任教授浪漫主义文学等的英语教授。
And they did what a lot of people did in that era. They moved to the country where it was cheaper. And we got an old beat up Victorian five acres. And there were streams and creeks and ponds and railroad tracks we could follow. And we just wandered after school. We didn't do any homework. And then as we got older, what we started to do, Shankar, is go to the rivers, you know, rafting. And then in particular to the Uber River, which is this wild river and jump into it. And so I had this incredible
他们做了那个时代很多人做的事。他们搬到了生活成本更低的乡村。我们买了一栋破旧的维多利亚式房子，占地五英亩。那里有小溪、小河、池塘和我们可以沿着走的铁路线。放学后我们就到处闲逛。我们不做任何家庭作业。然后随着我们长大，我们开始做的事情，尚卡尔，是去河流漂流。特别是去尤巴河，这是一条狂野的河流，我们会跳进河里。所以我拥有了
childhood of biking and walking out in the country. We lived on a dirt road where when I'd go walk home from the school dance, it was pitch black, and I'd see this giant sky of stars shooting stars. We slept outside, you know, so it was about wild awe. So that brings me to a question that I've been pondering for a bit in this conversation, which is that all in general seems like an ineffable emotion. It feels like it's very hard to wrap your arms around what exactly it is. And if you're going to study it scientifically, you have to know what it is that you're studying. So about 20 years ago, I understand that you and a
在乡村骑自行车和散步的不可思议的童年。我们住一条泥土路上，当我从学校舞会步行回家时，四周漆黑一片，我会看到这片巨大的星空和流星。我们在户外睡觉，你知道的，这一切都关乎野性的敬畏。这让我想到一个我在这场对话中一直在思考的问题，那就是敬畏总的来说似乎是一种难以言表的情感。感觉很难用双臂去环抱它究竟是什么。如果你要对它进行科学研究，你必须知道你正在研究的是什么。所以我听说大约20年前，你和一位
collaborator came up with a working definition of all. Can you tell me how that came about? Aw presents paradoxes, right? It seems ineffable and beyond words, but yet people really want to talk about it. It's mysterious and numinous, and we probably can measure it, and that's one of the tasks of science.
合作者提出了一个关于敬畏的工作定义。能告诉我那是怎么做到的吗？敬畏呈现出悖论，对吧？它似乎不可言喻，超乎言语，但人们确实很想谈论它。它既神秘又神圣，而我们或许可以衡量它，这是科学的任务之一。
So Jonathan Height, who is an early collaborator in my career and brilliant mind, we got invited to write a paper for a special issue on pleasure. And John and I had been talking about awe. And we said awe, real-the-key elements are when we encounter vast mysteries that we can't understand with our current knowledge or what we said was all requires what we call the need for accommodation. You have to rearrange your knowledge structures just to make sense of what you've encountered. But I think for our conversation today it's really all is encountering vast
所以乔纳森·海特，我职业生涯早期的合作者，一位才华横溢的思想家，我们受邀为一期关于愉悦的特刊撰写文章。我和约翰一直在讨论敬畏。我们说敬畏，真正关键的要素是当我们遇到我们用现有知识无法理解的巨大神秘时，或者我们所说的敬畏需要我们所说的心智调适需求。你必须重新排列你的知识结构，才能理解你所遇到的事物。但我认为对于我们今天的对话来说，真正重要的是敬畏是遇到我们不理解的巨大
mysteries that we don't understand. So nature is very often a common source of awe for many people. I want to play for you an audio clip. This is from a video made by a man named Paul Vasquez. His nickname is Bear. He saw something outside his home in your sanity. Whoa! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Whoa! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! It's full on! Double rainbow all the way across the sky.
神秘。因此，对许多人来说，大自然往往是敬畏的共同来源。我想为你播放一段音频剪辑。这是一个名叫保罗·瓦斯奎兹的人制作的视频。他的绰号是“熊”。他在优胜美地的家外看到了某种景象。哇！天哪！天哪！天哪！哇！天哪！天哪！天哪！太震撼了！双彩虹横跨整片天空。
Oh my God. So, Dacquery, you've seen this video, I believe. Yes. As a scientist, would you care to hazard a guess at what's happening inside Paul Vasquez's mind at that moment? This video is really what mystical experiences are like for people. They laugh, they use language that is expansive and beyond the usual kinds of terms you use.
天哪。所以，达卡，我相信你看过这个视频。是的。作为一名科学家，你愿意大胆猜测一下那一刻保罗·瓦斯奎兹脑海里在发生什么吗？这个视频确实展现了人们的神秘体验是什么样的。他们会笑，他们使用的语言是宏大的、超出了你通常使用的词汇范围。
It's full on, it's, oh my god, we cry, we are moved outside of ourselves. You know, I want to play you a clip from the end of the same video, Dakar, because it brings up something that I want to play you a clip from the end of the same video, Dacca, because it brings up something that I want to ask you about. Oh my god, the beam! Stop it! To watch a dog what it means. You know, it's interesting. Paul is almost uncomfortable by the intensity of the experience. He's struggling to understand what it means. And I think when most people think about all
太震撼了，天哪，我们会哭泣，我们被带出了自我。你知道的，我想给你播放这段视频结尾的一个片段，达卡，因为它引出了一些……我想给你播放同一视频结尾的一个片段，达卡，因为它引出了一些我想问你的事。天哪，那束光！停下来！去看看这意味着什么。你知道的，很有趣。保罗几乎对这种体验的强度感到不适。他在努力理解这意味着什么。我想当大多数人想到敬畏时，
they think about, okay, I'm seeing something beautiful. I see a beautiful sight, but I think we're getting into deeper waters here where all can actually make us uncomfortable. Yeah, you know, all destabilizes, it introduces profound uncertainty about our understanding of the world. It can be filled with threat. You know, when I sat amidst a storm, you know, I felt threatened. Just recently, I was backpacking with my daughter Natalie, high Sierra's, and we got caught in a lightning storm.
他们会想到，好吧，我看到了美丽的东西。我看到了美丽的风景，但我认为我们正在进入更深的水域，敬畏实际上会让我们感到不适。是的，你知道的，敬畏会打破平衡，它会为我们对世界的理解引入深刻的不确定性。它可能充满威胁。你知道的，当我坐在风暴之中时，我感到受到了威胁。就在最近，我和女儿娜塔莉一起在内华达山脉高地背包旅行，我们遭遇了一场雷暴。
And it was awe-inspiring and threatening. And that is true, I believe, with Vesquez's experience, the double rainbow experience. You know, when we no longer can make sense of reality, which is a theme of awe, it's that mystery, it's the need for finding new understandings of the world. Often we feel adrift, we feel anxious, we feel threatened, and we feel destabilized. You found that another realm of experience that tends to inspire all involves other people who do amazing things.
这既令人敬畏又充满威胁。我认为瓦斯奎兹的双彩虹体验也是如此。你知道的，当我们不再能理解现实时（这是敬畏的一个主题），那是一种神秘感，是寻找世界新理解的需求。通常我们会感到漂泊无依、感到焦虑、感到受威胁、感到平衡被打破。你发现另一种倾向于激发敬畏的体验领域涉及做出惊人举动的人。
Tell me about the idea of moral beauty, Dekka. You know, moral beauty is the idea that other people's kindness, encourage, and overcoming obstacles in their virtuosity, and their discipline can inspire us morally, where we see in them what we want to be as good human beings. And it astonished us, Chunker at the Berkeley Lab, that we sent out these requests, 26 countries, all these stories of awe come rolling in. And the most universal and the most common was the goodness or moral beauty of other people right around them.
达卡，跟我讲讲道德美的概念吧。你知道的，道德美是指其他人的善良、勇气、克服障碍的坚韧和他们的纪律可以在道德上激励我们，我们在他们身上看到了我们作为善良人类想要成为的样子。这让我们感到震惊，尚卡尔，在伯克利实验室，我们发出了这些请求，涉及26个国家，所有这些关于敬畏的故事纷至沓来。而最普遍、最常见的是他们周围其他人的善良或道德美。
And I'm not talking about Mahatma Skandi or Mother Teresa. It is like neighbors and strangers and grandmothers and the like. And roommates that almost on a weekly basis are triggering us to feel like God people are good. And I could be inspired by that. good and I could be inspired by that. I understand that you once had a powerful experience with a spiritual leader that also inspired a feeling of awe. Tell me about your encounter with the Dalai Lama. It makes me humble to talk about it. You know, I've been on two panels with his holiness, the Dalai Lama, and I'm like, man, I'm on a stage with the Dalai Lama, and there are 2500 people out in the audience.
我说的不是圣雄甘地或特蕾莎修女。而是邻居、陌生人、祖母之类的人。还有室友，他们几乎每周都在触发我们去感受到，天哪，人是善良的。我能从中受到启发。善良，我能从中受到启发。我听说你曾经与一位精神领袖有过一次强烈的体验，这也激发了敬畏感。跟我讲讲你与达赖喇嘛的相遇吧。谈起这个让我感到谦卑。你知道的，我和尊者达赖喇嘛一起参加过两次座谈会，我在想：天哪，我和达赖喇嘛同台，台下有2500人。
Before we go on, I greet his holiness. It's a profound moment. When he looks you in the eye, man, you feel like he is really looking me in the eye, and we hugged, and he kind of tickled me. And I was, and I literally, I was one giant goose bump. I was like, wow, I've just hugged and been tickled by the dollar lump. Then we go on stage.
在继续之前，我向尊者问好。这是一个深刻的时刻。当他看着你的眼睛时，伙计，你会觉得他真的在看着我的眼睛，我们拥抱了，他有点逗我笑。我当时，我字面意思，我全身起满了大鸡皮疙瘩。我当时想：哇，我刚刚被达赖喇嘛拥抱并逗笑了。然后我们上台。
And I'm asking him these dumb questions and the narrow scientist. And he's so engaged and interested and curious, you know, because he's training his mind in a way he's working harder on his mind than I've ever worked on anything. And at one moment in this conversation, I'm asking him about compassion, and he says, compassion is the natural state of the mind. And I, you know, coming out of my Western scientific homoeconomicist mindset, I was just, it was an epiphany. And epiphany are a very subtle source of all,
我问他那些愚蠢的问题，带着狭隘的科学家的视角。而他如此投入、感兴趣和好奇，你知道的，因为他在训练自己的心灵，他在心灵上下的功夫比我做过的任何事都要多。在这场对话的某个时刻，我问他关于同情心的问题，他说：“同情心是心灵的自然状态。”而我，你知道的，带着我那西方科学的“经济人”思维方式，这简直是一个顿悟。而顿悟是敬畏的一种非常微妙的来源，
where suddenly we grasp that there are big ideas that really make sense of a lot of things in reality. You might find epiphany in the idea of free markets or evolution or that capitalism is bad for the planet or big data or the idea of quantum physics, right? And it's surprisingly common around the world and has this structure to seeing suddenly being revealed to big ideas that help you make sense of the mysteries that concern you. And it was in all moment, right?
突然之间，我们领悟到有一些宏大的理念，它们确实解释了现实中的许多事物。你可能会在自由市场、进化论、资本主义对地球有害、大数据或量子物理学等理念中发现顿悟，对吧？这在世界各地出奇地普遍，并且具有这种结构：突然向你揭示那些有助于你理解令你困惑的谜团的宏大理念。那是一个充满敬畏的时刻，对吧？
I was like, wait a minute. Compassion is the deepest structure in the human mind, down in the midbrain, all these structures that have been part of mammalian evolution. And that animated a lot of research I did on compassion and changed how I teach, and it changed how I thought about humanity, you know, that there is this deep goodness in us that's part of our evolutionary story.
我当时想：等一下。同情心是人类心灵中最深层的结构，位于中脑深处，所有这些结构都是哺乳动物进化的一部分。这激发了我对同情心的大量研究，并改变了我的教学方式，也改变了我对人性的看法，你知道的，我们内心深处存在着这种属于我们进化故事一部分的深厚善良。
That's one of the most interesting parts of our evolutionary story, how good we are. And it blew my mind. You know, you talked about going to see Iggy Pop and then feeling like you could go on stage and talk to 300 students with newfound confidence. Did you find the same thing happened after meeting the Dalai Lama? Did your life feel different in the days and weeks that followed? After that experience with his holiness, the Dalai Lama, I felt like I had a deeper sense of purpose and meaning. And so, you know, I'm on an airplane and I had profound flight anxiety.
这是我们进化故事中最有趣的部分之一，即我们有多善良。这让我大开眼界。你知道的，你谈到去看伊基·波普的演出，然后觉得自己可以带着新发现的自信上台对300名学生讲话。你发现在见到达赖喇嘛后也发生了同样的事情吗？在接下来的几天和几周里，你的生活感觉有什么不同吗？在与尊者达赖喇嘛的那次经历之后，我感到了更深层次的目的感和意义感。所以，你知道的，我坐在一架飞机上，我曾经有严重的飞行焦虑。
Every little bump felt like the end of my life. I'd have images of losing my life and my children and so forth. And I noticed it, I wasn't anxious on the flight. I didn't need to power down a whiskey to make it home, you know. And then I got there and I was at the carousel and of course my luggage was lost and I literally laughed it off and I think I said, good, you know, it's time to shed all that stuff. I truly felt, and this is true of the science of awe, which is the mundane things don't get to you as much, and I felt above them and strong. So I think, you know, all of us have had these experiences where we have that warm glow, we get from, you know, an encounter with an awe-inspiring person or an experience.
每一个小颠簸都感觉像是生命的终结。我会产生失去生命、失去孩子等的画面。我注意到，我在这次飞行中并不焦虑。我不需要狂饮威士忌来撑到家，你知道的。然后我到达了目的地，我在行李转盘前，当然我的行李丢了，我字面意思是一笑置之，我想我当时说：“很好，你知道的，是时候摆脱所有这些东西了。”我真的感觉到——敬畏科学确实如此——那些琐碎的事情不再那么容易影响到你，我觉得自己超越了它们并且变得坚强。所以我想，你知道的，我们所有人都曾有过这样的体验：我们从与一个令人敬畏的人的相遇或一次体验中获得了那种温暖的光芒。
Is there any risk that could, that this can act, you know, like a kind of drug, that we get a high from feeling awestruck and inspired, and then this can lead us to be complacent or even oblivious to the sorrows or horrors of the world? Yeah, I think there are many risks of awe, right? This is a destabilizing emotion. It leads you to look for new knowledge to make sense of the world. It leads you to abandon past knowledge structures,
有没有任何风险，这可能会起作用，你知道的，就像某种药物，我们从感到敬畏和启发中获得快感，然后这会导致我们变得自满，甚至对世界的悲痛或恐怖视而不见？是的，我认为敬畏有很多风险，对吧？这是一种破坏稳定的情感。它引导你寻找新的知识来理解世界。它引导你放弃过去的知识结构，
perhaps, or assumptions. And a parent might think, well, that's what happened on my daughter when she joined a cult. Is this cult leader suddenly persuaded her to abandon life and follow this new on spying figure? You know, there's a new concern in the psychedelic movement of for certain people who find too much destabilizing search for new meaning in psychedelic experiences that can get them into trouble. You could go on. PR, Carlo, Valdezolo has nice studies showing that certain kinds of awe make us see patterns
也许还有假设。一位父母可能会想：“哦，这正是我女儿加入邪教时发生的事情。”这个邪教头目突然说服她放弃生活，去追随这个新的令人敬畏的人物？你知道的，在迷幻剂运动中出现了一种新的担忧：对于某些人在迷幻体验中寻找过多破坏稳定的新意义时，这可能会给他们带来麻烦。你可以继续说下去。
where there aren't patterns. And so we can believe things. Maybe a Q and on supporter feels goosebumps and awe at these stories that are absolute nonsense. They don't have a sense of boundaries. They enter into dangerous situations. So yeah, there are risks here that we should be attentive to. As there are, Sean Kerr, with every human passion.
普里·卡洛·瓦尔德索洛有很好的研究表明，某些种类的敬畏会让我们在没有规律的地方看到规律。因此我们可以相信一些事情。也许一个“匿名者Q”的支持者在这些绝对是无稽之谈的故事中感受到了鸡皮疙瘩和敬畏。他们没有边界感。他们进入了危险的境地。所以，是的，这里存在我们应该予以关注的风险。正如尚卡尔所说，人类的每一种激情都伴随着风险。
So you've become increasingly interested in the evolutionary origins of awe. Why is it that we would have an emotion like this? It's possible that other species also experience all, but of course, we don't typically see a line of cats sitting and watching a sunset together, right? We just, it just doesn't happen. So is there something that might explain our predisposition to all from an evolutionary perspective? You know, this is where the science of awe gets really interesting, which is how far back
所以你越来越对敬畏的进化起源感兴趣。为什么我们会拥有这样一种情感？其他物种也可能体验到敬畏，但当然，我们通常不会看到一排猫坐在一起看日落，对吧？我们只是，这根本不会发生。那么，从进化的角度来看，有什么可以解释我们对敬畏的倾向吗？你知道的，这就是敬畏科学变得非常有趣的地方，那就是我们可以将这种倾向追溯到我们灵长类和哺乳动物进化史的哪个阶段，对吧？如果它是一种基本情感，
in our primate mammalian evolution can retrace this, right? If it is a basic emotion, and we have a lot of data that suggests awe is as basic to humanity and the human species is anger or fear. And we have a lot of data on the expression of awe and what it does to our social behavior and sense of self that awe is this pretty deep human universal emotion. And I think that it does two things that are vital to our evolution.
我们有大量数据表明，敬畏对人类和人类物种而言，就像愤怒或恐惧一样基本。我们有大量关于敬畏的表达及其对我们的社会行为和自我意识的影响的数据，表明敬畏是一种相当深厚的人类普遍情感。我认为它做了两件对我们的进化至关重要的事情。
And the first is it connects the individual to collectives. And time and time again, when people experience all, they say things like I felt small and I felt like I was part of something larger than myself. And this is fundamental to our survival. And then the other thing that I think is really important, Chunker, is that awe helps us see the systems around us and understand them. One of the sets of operations of our mind is to be very narrow and focus on the self and individual actions and cause and affect relationships. The other is to look at the world holistically and systemically. That's an ecosystem. This is a social hierarchy. That is a musical structure. And awe pops those systems out to our awareness.
第一件事是将个体与集体联系起来。一次又一次，当人们体验到敬畏时，他们会说出这样的话：“我觉得自己很渺小，我觉得自己是比自我更宏大的事物的一部分。”这对于我们的生存至关重要。另一件我认为非常重要的事，尚卡尔，是敬畏帮助我们看到周围的系统并理解它们。我们心智的一组运作方式是高度局限的，专注于自我、个体行为以及因果关系。另一种是宏观和系统地看待世界。那是一个生态系统。这是一个社会等级。那是一个音乐结构。而敬畏将这些系统凸显到我们的意识中。
So it really is the animator of a systems view of life. And that's really important for scientific understanding, for social understanding, for knowing where to find resources in my environment, right, to understand my ecology, and all is the great engine of a system's view of the world. You know, so much of it begins with the feeling that all can produce in us of making us feel small. I remember visiting Alaska once and feeling like I was a very small creature and a very very big planet. And you've done studies looking at the same idea.
所以它确实是生命系统观的推动者。这对于科学理解、社会理解、了解在我的环境中哪里可以找到资源来说真的非常重要，对吧，去理解我的生态，而敬畏是世界系统观的伟大引擎。你知道的，这其中很大一部分始于敬畏在我们体内产生的那种让我们觉得自己渺小的感觉。我记得有一次去阿拉斯加访问，觉得自己是一个非常巨大的星球上的一个非常非常小的生物。而你也做过研究，探讨过相同的想法。
You ran an interesting study in Yosemite exploring this idea that all changes are sense of our own scale. You know the self takes up a lot of area in the brain and in our consciousness. We're always thinking especially in this modern world about my goals, my status, my my aspirations, I'm doing, my desires, my interests. And evolutionists have really talked about the problem of self-interest. How do we get people to orient to other people, to societies and collectives. And we started to have this idea that awe does that by creating the small self. In a lot of writings about all, right, religious writings from centuries ago, nature writings, Ralph Waldo Emerson, his big epiphany, I am nothing,
你在优胜美地做过一项有趣的研究，探讨了敬畏会改变我们对自己规模感知的观点。你知道的，自我占用了大脑和意识中的很大一部分区域。我们总是在思考，特别是在这个现代世界里，关于我的目标、我的地位、我的抱负、我在做的事、我的欲望、我的利益。进化论者一直在讨论自利的问题。我们如何让人类关注其他人、社会和集体？我们开始有这样一个想法：敬畏通过创造“小自我”来实现这一点。在关于敬畏的许多著作中，对吧，几个世纪前的宗教著作、自然文学、拉尔夫·沃尔多·梅森的重大顿悟——我什么都不是，
right? Psychedelic writings, all these writings are speaking to this, but we had to get it empirically. So my collaborator, Young By, from China, went to Yosemite, stopped travelers from 42 countries at this particular outlook on a road where you first get to see Yosemite Valley and El Capitan and the great granite slabs and this incredible valley that's just awe-inspiring. And what Young By did is she did a really simple task. She had people at that moment draw themselves and write me. And in that context, those drawings of the self were really small. They wrote their sense of me, really small compared to the right kind of control conditions. And we have other data and really different kinds of data, even neuroscientific data showing
对吧？迷幻文学，所有这些著作都在谈论这一点，但我们需要通过经验数据来证实。因此，我来自中国的合作者杨白（音译）前往优胜美地，在这条道路上特定观景点的42个国家旅行者拦了下来，在那里你第一次能看到优胜美地山谷、埃尔卡皮坦巨岩、巨大的花岗岩石板和这个令人惊叹的山谷，它简直令人敬畏。而杨白做的是一件非常简单的事。她让人们在那一刻画出自己并写下关于“我”的内容。在这种背景下，那些关于自我的画作真的很小。与适当的控制条件相比，他们写下的“我”的感知真的很小。我们有其他数据以及完全不同种类的数据，甚至是神经科学数据，显示
all quiets, this egoistic, self-focused sense of personal identity and opens you up to the big things that you're connected to. You and your collaborator, Lani Shiora, also once had people stand in front of an enormous T.Rex skeleton. Tell me about that experiment, Ducker. On the Berkeley campus, we have this incredible replica of a T.Rex skeleton, and it's in our museum of paleontology, and you stand next to it. And we did the pilot testing. People say, I feel all, man, this is amazing.
敬畏能平息这种利己的、以自我为中心的个人认同感，并让你向与之相连的宏大事物开放。你和你的合作者拉尼·希奥拉（音译）也曾让人们站在一具巨大的霸王龙骨架前。达卡，跟我讲讲那个实验吧。在伯克利校园里，我们有这个令人难以置信的霸王龙骨架复制品，它在我们的古生物学博物馆里，你就站在它旁边。我们做了预实验。人们说：“我觉得敬畏，伙计，这太棒了。”
It's huge. Imagine being chased by that thing, you know? Wow, those things existed 70 million years ago. It's awesome. So Lonnie and our team stood Berkeley undergraduates by this T-Rex, or they stood in the opposite direction looking down a hallway. And there's this classic measure of your own self for identity, which is you are given the stem, I am.
太巨大了。想象一下被那种东西追赶，你知道的？哇，那些东西在7000万年前就存在了。这太棒了。所以拉尼和我们的团队让伯克利本科生站在这个霸王龙旁边，或者让他们面向相反方向看着一条走廊。这里有一个经典的衡量你自我或认同感的标准，那就是给你一个词干：我是。
And next to it is a blank line and you just fill it in 20 different times. And typically people living in the West will say things like, I am extroverted, and I am ambitious, and I am interested in this, and when they stood next to that T-Rex and took it in and felt awe, their sense of self expanded and themes of common humanity emerged. I am a human. I am a mammal. I am a part of California. I am of this ethnic variety. And so this collective communal self emerged. And that's the power of all. A little moment, 30 seconds of it, you shift from self-focus, very narrow to, wow, I'm part of something really large. And some of this translates not just to how we think about ourselves in our translates not just to how we think
旁边是一条空白线，你只需要把它填满20次。通常生活在西方的人会说这样的话：“我是外向的，我是有雄心壮志的，我对这个感兴趣”，而当他们站在那头霸王龙旁边吸收这种景象并感受到敬畏时，他们的自我感扩大了，共同人性的主题浮现出来。我是人类。我是哺乳动物。我是加利福尼亚的一部分。我属于这个族裔。因此，这种集体的、群体的自我浮现了。这就是敬畏的力量。一个短暂的时刻，30秒钟，你从高度局限的自我中心转向：哇，我是某个非常宏大事物的一部分。其中一些不仅转化为我们在头脑中如何看待自己，
about ourselves in our own minds, but how we're acting towards other people. You also ran another experiment on the Berkeley campus this time involving a grow of eucalyptus trees. Tell me about that study, Dr. Yeah, you know, one of the beauties of awe and to understand it, it brings out the best of our imagination, you know, and My lab started to get interested in on we were throwing around all these ideas and doing these crazy studies and the very
还转化为我们对其他人的行为方式。你还在伯克利校园里进行了另一项实验，这次涉及一片桉树林。达卡，跟我讲讲那项研究吧。是的，你知道的，敬畏的美妙之处在于理解它，它能激发我们想象力的最好部分，你知道的，我的实验室开始对敬畏产生兴趣，我们到处抛出这些想法并做这些疯狂的实验，现在是加州大学欧文分校教授的充满想象力的保罗·皮夫做了一项研究，他把本科生带到一个桉树林里，
imaginative Paul Piff now a professor at UC Irvine Did a study in which he took undergrads to a eucalyptus grove and And their blue gum eucalyptus trees, there's some of the tallest in North America. When you look up into them, they're light and the colors and the leaves and their fragrances are just astonishing. That grove, when you stand in the middle of them,
那里有蓝胶桉树，它们是北美最高的树木之一。当你抬头仰望它们时，光线、色彩、树叶和它们的芳香简直令人惊叹。当你站在那片树林的中央时，
embraces you. It makes you feel like you're a part of them. And in the control condition, people in the same place, but they looked at this science building. And lo and behold, you know, Shankar, this is a minute or two of just, for no reason, looking up into these trees. In one to two minutes, our students reported
它拥抱了你。它让你觉得你是它们的一部分。而在对照组中，人们在同一个地方，但他们看着这栋科学大楼。结果发现，你知道的，尚卡尔，这只是一两分钟的时间，无缘无故地抬头仰望这些树木。在短短一两分钟内，我们的学生报告说
feeling less narcissistic, less entitled. They needed less money to do this study when we offered to pay them. And then Paul staged this accident where a student was walking by and they dropped some pens and the people feeling aw, picked up more pens, right? They, and we replicated that and tightly controlled laboratory studies.
感觉自己不那么自恋了，不那么有特权感了。当我们提议付钱给他们时，他们完成这项研究所需的报酬也更少了。然后保罗上演了这样一场意外：一个学生走过时掉落了一些铅笔，而感受到敬畏的人捡起了更多的铅笔，对吧？他们……我们在严格控制的实验室研究中复制了这一结果。
You just share more when you're feeling aw, you cooperate more, you give more, just with a minute or two of looking it up at some trees. You know, very much like you described about your own experiences in Wisconsin. Yeah. You and Jonathan Hyte have said that an experience of awe can press a reset button in the mind. What do you mean by that, Dacker? Reset buttons are really interesting. And actually, you know, Sylvan Tomkins wrote about when you're startled by a loud clap of thunder or the appearance of an old friend or bumping into a friend in the street, it kind of restarts your mind. It resets it to look at things anew and fresh and and contemplative people might say with
当你感到敬畏时，你会乐于分享，你会更多地合作，你会给予更多，仅仅通过花一两分钟抬头看看树木。你知道，这很像你所描述的你在威斯康星州的亲身经历。是的。你和乔纳森·海特曾说过，敬畏的体验可以在大脑中按下重置键。达克，你这话是什么意思？重置键确实很有趣。事实上，你知道的，西尔万·汤姆金斯曾写过，当你被一声巨响吓到，或者看到一位老朋友出现，或者在街上偶遇朋友时，它会在某种程度上重启你的大脑。它将大脑重置，以一种崭新、新鲜的方式去看待事物，而沉思的人可能会说，带着
a beginner's mind. And that's what awe does for a shanker. When we come back, how to bring more awe into our lives? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. At UC Berkeley, Psychologist Dackardeltener studies the benevolent emotions, including the emotion of all. He's the author of the book, all, the new science of everyday wonder, and how it can transform
赤子之心。这就是敬畏对香卡的作用。稍后回来，我们探讨如何将更多的敬畏带入生活？欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。在加州大学伯克利分校，心理学家达克尔·凯尔特纳研究仁爱的情感，包括敬畏的情感。他是《敬畏：日常惊奇的新科学以及它如何改变》一书的作者。
your life. Dackert, you recently studied the effects of all on disadvantaged students and military veterans, neither felt much or in their regular lives. What did you do? What did the study involve? Yeah, you know, there's a growing interest in our culture and scientifically about how the institutional, structural traumas of life, if you're impoverished and you don't have parks nearby and the like, or you have a career
你的生活。达克，你最近研究了敬畏对弱势学生和退伍军人的影响，他们两类人在日常生活中都很少感受到敬畏。你们是怎么做的？这项研究包含哪些内容？是的，你知道的，我们的文化和科学界越来越关注这样一个问题：生活中制度化、结构化的创伤，比如如果你身处贫困，附近没有公园之类的地方，或者你有一份职业
like veterans who go see combat and see people die, their profiles look traumatized. They are depressed, and vigilant, anxious very often, twice the rates of American citizens, elevated levels of cortisol and inflammation and the like. And I became friends with Stacey Bear, who's a veteran and we started talking about this. And he leads veterans into outdoors programs. And so what we decided to do in this study is we got veterans and high school students who were in really tough, impoverished schools in parts of the East Bay in California. And it's where there are bars and police cars and no gardens, et cetera.
像那些经历过战斗、眼睁睁看着人死去的退伍军人一样，他们的特征看起来就像是受过创伤。他们往往感到抑郁、高度警惕、焦虑，其比率是美国普通公民的两倍，皮质醇水平和炎症等指标也有所升高。我和退伍军人斯泰西·贝尔成了朋友，我们开始讨论这件事。他带领退伍军人参与户外项目。因此，我们决定在这项研究中招募退伍军人和高中生，他们来自加州东湾地区一些真正艰难、贫困的学校。那里到处都是酒吧、警车，却没有花园等等。
And these kids hadn't been outside in parks. They hadn't gone camping. Many of them had not really seen a night sky of stars. So we took them rafting. Our veterans and then our high schoolers down the American river on a stretch and it's beautiful and you wind through these rapids and you look at the water and you see fish and it's amazing. And what we found, we measured their emotions and stress and trauma and sense of connection at the start of the study a week later. And as the study unfolded, we measured their sense of wonder and awe and connection to their
这些孩子从来没有去过外面的公园。他们没有去过露营。他们中的许多人甚至从未真正见过布满繁星的夜空。于是我们带着他们去漂流。我们的退伍军人和高中生一起顺着美国河的一段河域漂流，那里景色优美，你穿过急流，看着水流，还能看到鱼，非常奇妙。我们发现，我们在研究开始时测量了他们的情绪、压力、创伤和连接感，以及一周后再次测量。随着研究的展开，我们测量了他们的惊奇感、敬畏感以及与
peers and cortisol and emotions. And what we found is our high schoolers, a week later, felt less stress, more happiness, they felt more connected to their community and family. And our veterans felt 30% less PTSD. One high schooler said, I'm so struck by the rolling hills and the smoke, and it was smoky at the time because of wildfires, and the water. And then a veteran said, and I love this quote where, you know, the star-splatted sky made me realize that my worries are not as important as I thought they are, but what
同龄人的连接感、皮质醇和情绪。我们发现，一周后，我们的高中生压力更小，更快乐，他们觉得与社区和家庭的联系更紧密了。而我们的退伍军人，其创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）减轻了30%。一名高中生说：“起伏的山丘和烟雾深深震撼了我——当时因为野火到处都是烟雾——还有水。”接着，一位退伍军人说，我非常喜欢这句话：“你知道，星光灿烂的天空让我意识到，我的烦恼其实并没有我想象的那么重要，但
I could do in the world is more important. And so it was this nice study, and there's a lot of science on this of different varieties that nature emerged and in finding awe, gardening, walking, gaining out into the woods, standing near a tree is good for your nervous system and your mind. Is there any evidence that awe has physiological effects on us? Yeah, there are, you know, there's this thing called the vagus nerve, largest bundle of nerves in your body. It slows heart rate, deep and breathing, regulates digestion, helps with your gut and the microbiome. In general, people have
我在世界上能做的事情却更加重要。”这是一个很好的研究，而且有许多不同种类的科学研究表明，走向大自然、寻找敬畏、园艺、散步、走进树林、站在树旁，对你的神经系统和大脑都有好处。有没有证据表明敬畏对我们的生理有影响呢？是的，有的，你知道，有个东西叫迷走神经，它是你体内最大的神经束。它能减慢心率、加深呼吸、调节消化，并对肠道和微生物群有所帮助。总的来说，人们拥有
a nice functioning vagus nerve that is responsive and as elevated levels do better in life. And we found, thanks to Amy Gordon and Jenny Stellar, you know, that little brief experiences of awe, seeing an inspiring image, hearing about moral beauty, elevates your vagus nerve activation. And then just as impressively, you know, when you're immune system, the cytokine system more specifically, cranks out these proteins that attack pathogens. And that's the inflammation response that makes you feel feverish and sluggish and overheated.
一个功能良好、反应灵敏且水平较高的迷走神经，在生活中会过得更好。多亏了艾米·戈尔顿和珍妮·斯特勒的研究，我们发现，短暂的敬畏体验——看到一张鼓舞人心的图片，听到关于道德之美的故事——就能提升迷走神经的激活水平。同样令人印象深刻的是，你知道的，当你的免疫系统（更具体地说是细胞因子系统）大量制造出攻击病原体的蛋白质时，这就是引发你发烧、迟钝和体温过高的炎症反应。
It's good when you're fighting a virus. It's not good if you're chronically inflamed and it's one of the central threats to health in the United States. And Jenny, Stellar, and Neha, John Henderson, went out and found in our lab that feeling a lot of awe of all the positive emotions, quiets down the inflammation response. So it tells us, you know, Emerson, when he had this big epiphany of awe out on a cold day in Massachusetts, he said, there is nothing that nature cannot repair. And I think he was feeling these changes in the body of vagal tone and inflammation, reduced inflammation, that all gives us. So, Dakra, you've described many ways in which all is good for us,
当你对抗病毒时，这是件好事。但如果你处于慢性炎症中，这就不是好事了，这也是美国健康面临的核心威胁之一。珍妮·斯特勒和内哈·约翰·亨德森在我们的实验室里发现，在所有的积极情绪中，感受到大量的敬畏能够平息炎症反应。这告诉我们，正如爱默生在马萨诸塞州一个寒冷的日子里产生关于敬畏的巨大顿悟时所说的那样：“大自然没有什么不能修复的。”我想他当时感受到的正是身体内部迷走神经张力和炎症的变化，即敬畏带给我们的炎症减轻。所以，达克，你描述了许多敬畏对我们有益的方式，
but you also said that our society is becoming all deprived. What do you mean by that? The deeper structural conditions of our lives are in some ways, especially for young people today, working against awe. And I really sense this teaching thousands of students a year at a big university like Berkeley. They are awe-deprived because too much is structured and they are not allowed to wander, like I did as a kid, wandering around the neighborhoods and out in the foothills. They are all deprived because of the new technologies, which frankly just get us too focused on the self.
但你也说过，我们的社会正在变得“缺乏敬畏”。你这话是什么意思？我们生活的更深层的结构性条件在某些方面正在消解敬畏，特别是对于今天的年轻人来说。我在一所像伯克利这样的大学里每年教成千上万的学生，对此有着深刻的体会。他们缺乏敬畏，是因为生活被安排得太有条理了，他们不被允许像我小时候那样到处闲逛，在街区和山麓里游荡。由于新技术的出现，他们缺乏敬畏，坦白说，新技术让我们过于关注自我。
The more we're focused on the self, the narrow parts of the self, the less awe we feel. They're all deprived because of all the competitive self comparisons that have arisen today. So are people getting enough of it? No, we need more awe right now. You know, Lancet publication recently showed that the pandemic has led to rises in depression and anxiety by 20 to 30%.
我们越是关注自我、关注狭隘的自我，我们感到的敬畏就越少。由于当今涌现出各种好胜的自我比较，他们也缺乏敬畏。那么人们得到的敬畏足够吗？不，我们现在需要更多的敬畏。你知道，发表在《柳叶刀》上的一项研究最近显示，大流行导致抑郁和焦虑水平上升了20%到30%。
We've all felt this, our young people in particular. But there is everyday awe. And if we just take a little moment to get out and look for it, it's there to find. So, so, Dacquian, one recent study you had volunteer stake in awe, walk. What is an awe walk? One of the easiest ways to find awe is to, in an unbounded way, go out and walk. We have been doing this as humans for a long time in their spiritual, contemplative traditions, getting out into nature and doing all walks as just part of those traditions. And what we decided to do is test its benefits scientifically.
我们都深有体会，尤其是我们的年轻人。但日常生活中其实处处有敬畏。如果我们抽出一点时间走出去寻找它，它是能够被找到的。那么，达克，你最近的一项研究让志愿者进行了一次“敬畏漫步”。什么是“敬畏漫步”？寻找敬畏最简单的方法之一，就是以一种无拘无束的方式走出去散步。作为人类，我们长期以来一直在这样做，在精神和沉思的传统中，走到大自然中去进行敬畏漫步正是这些传统的一部分。我们决定以科学的方法来测试它的益处。
And so I wrote up these instructions for an aw-walk. And what you do is you take your ordinary walk that a lot of people do, and in fact during the pandemic there are historic levels of walking. And you not only go out to do it vigorously and to help your heart, but you go with a child like sense of wonder and you just stop and reflect on what is really interesting and the small things around you, the flowers and patterns of shadows and like, and also look up, pass the horizon and look up to vast things, right?
因此，我为敬畏漫步写了这些说明。你所做的就是进行许多人都会进行的普通散步，事实上在大流行期间散步达到了历史最高水平。你不仅是为了充满活力地锻炼心脏而出门，而是带着一种孩子般的惊奇感去散步，你会停下来反思周围真正有趣的小事物，比如花朵、阴影的图案等等，同时还要抬头，越过地平线去仰望宏大的事物，对吧？
And do it in a way where you go places that you're curious about. where you go places that you're curious about. And in this study, what we did is our participants were all 75 years old or older. That is an age where because we have a sense that death is coming and we see people die, we're a little bit more anxious at that stage of life. And so one group of our participants did an all walk once a week for eight weeks. The other group of participants, tight control, did a vigorous walk once a week.
并且以一种去你感到好奇的地方的方式去走。并且以一种去你感到好奇的地方的方式去走。在这项研究中，我们的参与者都是75岁或以上的老人。这是一个这样的年龄：因为我们意识到死亡即将来临，且看到周围的人离去，我们在人生这个阶段会感到更加焦虑。因此，我们的一组参与者连续八周，每周进行一次敬畏漫步。另一组参与者作为严密的对照组，每周进行一次充满活力的健步走。
Each time they did a walk, they took a picture of themselves. And then we gathered a bunch of self-reports, like how are they doing on a daily basis? How is their levels of anxiety and so forth. And we found just a couple of things. One, the more you do the awl walk, the more awe-inspiring it becomes. awe doesn't diminish with experience. It gets richer and deeper. By the end of the eight weeks our awl walk participants were feeling a lot of awe. Two more changes in the self. There are pictures of themselves.
每次散步时，他们都会给自己拍张照片。然后我们收集了大量自我报告，比如他们日常过得怎么样？他们的焦虑水平如何，等等。我们发现了几点。第一，你进行敬畏漫步的次数越多，它所激发的情感就越丰富。敬畏不会随着经验而减弱。它变得更丰富、更深刻。到第八周结束时，我们的敬畏漫步参与者感受到了大量的敬畏。第二，自我发生了更多改变。这里有他们自己的照片。
And I love this finding. The self gets smaller over time. And it starts to drift off to the side. And they're including, you know, the rocks and scut sunsets of their awak. And then third, really importantly, on on a daily basis they just felt less distress you know they felt less anxiety about life. You know in many ways in this conversation Dacca we've spent a lot of time talking about all in
我非常喜欢这个发现。随着时间推移，自我变得更小了。并且开始退居一旁。他们的眼中开始容纳（你知道的）他们敬畏漫步中看到的岩石和日落。第三，非常重要的一点是，在日常生活中，他们感到的痛苦减少了，你知道的，他们对生活的焦虑感减少了。你知道，在这次对话中，达克，我们花了很多时间讨论
the in the beautiful in the majestic but you've written that so much of life is awesome, including the parts that are not great. Tell me about your relationship with your brother, Ralph. You were very close to him, right? Yeah, you know, just hearing you say his name brings goosebumps and tears to me. He was born one year after me, so he was younger. And we did everything together. We played little league together, we played basketball teams together, wandered together, went to Mexico together, we're best men in each other's weddings. We both became social science teacher types. And frankly, he taught me how to be kinder and how to be courageous. I don't think I was in doubt with those tendencies early.
美好与宏伟之中的敬畏，但你也写过，生活中的许多事情都令人敬畏，包括那些并不美好的部分。跟我讲讲你和你的哥哥拉尔夫的关系吧。你跟他非常亲近，对吧？是的，你知道，只要听到你念出他的名字，我就会起鸡皮疙瘩并流泪。他比我小一岁，所以他是弟弟。我们形影不离。我们一起打小联盟，一起加入篮球球队，一起闲逛，一起去墨西哥，我们在彼此的婚礼上担任伴郎。我们俩都成了社会科学老师类型的人。坦白说，他教会了我如何更善良、如何勇敢。我早期并不具备这些特质。
He taught me. He was my example in many ways of moral beauty. So I was profoundly close to him through the ebbs and flows of brotherhood, but he was my core. So I understand a few years ago, he was diagnosed with colon cancer. Tell me about that, Dacker. Anyone out listening, who's been close to colon cancer,
是他教导了我。在许多方面，他是道德之美的典范。因此，在兄弟情谊的起起伏伏中，我与他无比亲密，他就是我的核心。据我所知，几年前，他被诊断出患有结肠癌。能跟我说说这事吗，达克？任何收听节目的、经历过身边人患结肠癌的人都知道，
it's a horror show. And for my brother, for two years, I watched him go from being a 210 pound, watched him go from being a 210 pound very strong man, 147 pounds, bone thin, passing out. There's a lot of pain, but there are certain kinds of pain that just wipe out consciousness, breakthrough pain. And abdominal pain is like that. He got it all, chemotherapy, and I was just there all the time. And then he decided to take a cocktail when he knew the cancer had returned and headed into his gut.
那真是一场噩梦。对于我哥哥，在两年的时间里，我看着他从一个210磅重、看着他从一个210磅重、非常强壮的男子，变成147磅，骨瘦如柴，不断晕倒。有许多疼痛，但有些疼痛会直接抹去意识，那就是爆发痛。腹痛就是这种感觉。他经受了这一切，化疗，而我一直陪在他身边。后来，当他得知癌症复发并侵入肠道时，他决定服用鸡尾酒疗法。
And we all went up there in January and we watched him, you know, slowly leave this world. in a slowly leave this world. And Shankar, I had gone through the most horrifying two years of my life, watching my companion in awe, my brother, Ralph, fade physically. But in that moment of seeing him calmer, heading into where he was going after losing his body, we were all around him, we touched him, the light felt different, we were quiet, we bowed our heads, and we were all in reverence of my brother, Ralph, and what he meant.
我们在1月都赶了过去，看着他，你知道的，慢慢地离开这个世界。慢慢地离开这个世界。香卡，我经历了人生中最可怕的两年，看着我的敬畏旅伴、我的哥哥拉尔夫身体日渐衰弱。但在看到他变得平静、在失去肉体后走向他该去的地方的那一刻，我们都围在他身边，触摸着他，光线感觉变得不同了，我们安然静默，我们低下头，对我的哥哥拉尔夫以及他所代表的意义充满敬意。
And watching him go, I was filled with astonishment and awe. I understand that you took a trip to honor your brother's memory after he died. Where did you go, Dacca? After he died, and then I returned to my life in Berkeley and was blown off the map. And it's really the state that Joan Didian describes, you know, in her writing about grief. I couldn't sleep and anxious and confused and was just really struggling. And this voice came to me and it was fine to awe. And my brother and I, we always went to the mountains. You know, we grew up in the mountains near the sierra's and I went up in the high sierra's and
看着他离去，我心中充满了惊异和敬畏。我听说在他去世后，你进行了一次旅行来纪念他。你去了哪里，达克？在他去世后，我回到了伯克利的生活中，却感觉被世界抛弃了。这确实是琼·迪迪安在她关于悲伤的著作中所描述的那种状态。我无法入眠，感到焦虑和困惑，正苦苦挣扎。这时，一个声音在我心中响起，那就是去寻找敬畏。我和我哥哥以前总是去山里。你知道，我们在内华达山脉附近的群山中长大，我去了内华达山脉的高处，
ducts like where he and I had hiked and mammoth in the east side of the sierra's when I saw the ridge line that he and I had seen. I felt him there. I heard his voice. I saw the trees that he and I had seen. These trees flicker in the wind. The aspen trees. And I just felt him there, Shankar.
去寻找我和他曾一起徒步的地方，在内华达山脉东侧的猛犸山，当我看到我和他曾见过的那道山脊线时。我在那里感受到了他。我听到了他的声音。我看到了他和我都见过的那些树。这些树在风中摇曳。白杨树。我在那里感受到了他，香卡。
I was like, in these mountains, my brother is with me. Dagger Kaltner is a psychologist at the University of California Berkeley. He's the author of all, the new science of everyday wonder and how it can transform your life. Dacker, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it is a privilege to be in conversation with you. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget MacArthur, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. As many of you know, we recently started a new show called My Unsung Hero. It's designed to
我当时想，在这群山之中，我的哥哥与我同在。达克尔·凯尔特纳是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学家。他是《敬畏：日常惊奇的新科学以及它如何改变你的生活》一书的作者。达克，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。香卡，能与你对话是我的荣幸。谢谢你。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦克阿瑟、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·黄、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。正如你们许多人所知，我们最近开办了一个新节目，叫做《我身边的无名英雄》。它旨在
show you that the world is filled with everyday acts of kindness and courage. As I've listened to stories of unsung heroes, I've often found myself moved to tears. But it wasn't until I talked to Dacca that I realized, these are really stories about moral beauty. The reason these stories make me want to be a better person, they're giving me a feeling of awe. Please subscribe to my unsung hero podcast. Here's a taste of what it's like.
向你展示世界上充满了日常的善良与勇敢的行为。当我聆听那些无名英雄的故事时，我常常感动得落泪。但直到我与达克交谈，我才意识到，这些其实都是关于道德之美的故事。这些故事之所以让我想要成为一个更好的人，是因为它们带给我一种敬畏感。请订阅我的“无名英雄”播客。以下是其中的精彩片段。
This story comes from Ali Ward. In 2013, Ali's life felt like it was collapsing. Her relationship with her partner fell apart, her new job wasn't working out, and her father was diagnosed with a rare form of cancer. Meanwhile, my dad's brother had the same kind of cancer and died. And there was a lot going on. I remember days when I would think I only cried four times today. That was a good day for me. It was just really tough. It was a lot of things that I just couldn't help.
这个故事来自阿里·沃德。2013年，阿里的生活感觉像是崩塌了。她与伴侣的关系破裂了，新工作不如意，父亲又被诊断出患有一种罕见的癌症。与此同时，我爸爸的弟弟也得了同一种癌症并去世了。当时事情实在太多了。我记得有些日子，我会想：“我今天只哭了四次。”那对我来说就算是好日子了。那段日子真的很艰难。有太多事情是我无能为力的。
When she needed a distraction, Ali liked to go on Facebook and post pictures of her unconventional obsession. Bugs. Worms. Spiders. Brightly colored beetles. Her close friends found it endearing, but in Los Angeles, where she lived, not everyone got it. There's, you know, a little bit of Artifice in LA and you don't find a lot of people that get excited about a spiderweb. One day, she got a Facebook message from a friend of a friend, a woman she had never met
当她需要转移注意力时，阿里喜欢登录Facebook，发布她那非主流痴迷的照片。虫子。蠕虫。蜘蛛。色彩鲜艳的甲虫。她的挚友们觉得这很可爱，但在她居住的洛杉矶，并不是每个人都能理解。你知道的，洛杉矶有一点矫揉造作，你很难找到一群对蜘蛛网感到兴奋的人。有一天，她收到了一条来自朋友的朋友的Facebook消息，这个女人她从未见过，
named Lila Higgins. Lila was an entomologist at the local natural history museum and she had noticed Ali's quirky bug pictures. So she reached out. And she said, I heard you like bugs. If you want to come check, there's this insectery in the middle of like the catacombs, the inner workings of museum, just come and check out some bugs. Lila had no idea what I was going through in my life at that time. I think she probably didn't expect someone jittery and tear stage to meet her at the back door of this museum.
名叫莉拉·希金斯。莉拉是当地自然历史博物馆的昆虫学家，她注意到了阿里那些古怪的虫子照片。于是她主动联系了她。她说：“我听说你喜欢虫子。如果你想来看看，博物馆的地下墓穴也就是内部运作区域中间有一个昆虫馆，快来参观一些虫子吧。”莉拉当时根本不知道我生活中正在经历什么。我想她可能没料到会在博物馆后门见到一个神经质、泪眼汪汪的人。
But this is my jam. I have loved bugs since I was a little kid. There is nothing I wanted more than to see some scorpions and some larvae. I was like, I would love this. And I went and was just delighted by it. I got to put on a lab coat. I got to go through some secret doors,
但这正是我的最爱。我从小就喜欢虫子。没有什么比看一些蝎子和幼虫更让我渴望的了。当时我想：“太棒了，我太乐意了。”我去了，简直欣喜若狂。我穿上了实验室白大褂。我穿过了一些秘密门，
some employee-only areas. And I remember she opened up this freezer, like come check this out. And then just, errr, this freezer opening, like a coffin. And it was full of dead bugs, dead tarantulas, some stick insects, I mean, big scorpions,
一些仅限员工进入的区域。我记得她打开了这个冰柜，说：“快来看看这个。”然后伴随着“咔哒”一声，冰柜像棺材一样打开了。里面全是死虫子、死狼蛛、一些竹节虫，我的意思是，还有大蝎子，
I mean, all kinds of things that have passed away, but they were saving them for the Entomology Department or just for posterity. And I just remember just how excited she was about everything was such a pass for me to get excited about this in her company and Really rediscover what excited me in life You know at the end she said you should volunteer here
我的意思是，各种各样已经死去的生物，但它们被保存在昆虫学系里，或者只是为了流传后世。我只记得她对这一切都充满热情，这极大地感染了我，让我在她的陪伴下也对这些事情兴奋不已，并且重新发现了生活中让我兴奋的事物。你知道，在最后她说：“你应该来这里做志愿者。”
And I remember I mean I was like in between crying Jags that day and I was like How could my life get a lot worse? I can afford three hours a week So I started volunteering and I just would really light up. It gave me this sense of purpose. It helped me reconnect with my love of science and nature that I'd always had. You know, Lila Higgins just in one instant changed my whole life.
我记得，我的意思是，那天我还在痛哭流涕的间隙，心想：“我的生活还能怎么更糟糕呢？我每周还是能抽出三个小时的。”于是我开始做志愿者，整个人真的焕发了生机。这赋予了我一种使命感。它帮我重新找回了自己一直以来对科学和大自然的热爱。你知道，莉拉·希金斯就在那一瞬间改变了我整个人生。
And I think that she's impacted a lot of lives that she probably doesn't understand. You know, I think that it's impacted a lot of lives that she probably doesn't understand, you know. I think that it's just in a day's work for her to point out snails and slugs and butterflies. And, you know, Mozeon keep doing her job, and I don't think that she understands a ripple effect that she has. She has caused such an exponential effect I think in my life, I felt like I came home to myself because of the way that she can be herself. Ali Ward lives in Los Angeles. Since she quit that job she didn't like, she has started her own science podcast. It's called Oligies.
我想她也影响了许多她自己可能并不了解的人生。你知道，我想她可能并不了解自己对许多人生产生了影响。你知道，我觉得对她来说，指出蜗牛、蛞蝓和蝴蝶不过是日常工作的一部分，而且，你知道的，莫泽一直在做她的工作，我不认为她明白自己所产生的连锁反应。她在我的生活中引发了如此巨大的指数级效应，我觉得因为她那种能够做自己的方式，我终于找到了真正的自我。阿里·沃德住在洛杉矶。自从她辞去了那份不喜欢的工作后，她创办了自己的科学播客。它叫《Ologies》。
If you found our happiness 2.0 series useful and inspiring, please take a moment and tell a friend or colleague about our show. Think of one person who might enjoy our program and tell them about it. Another way you can support us is by supporting us. Help us build more shows like this by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you soon. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你觉得我们的“幸福 2.0”系列有用且富有启发性，请花一点时间将我们的节目推荐给你的朋友或同事。想想可能会喜欢我们节目的一个人，并告诉他们。你支持我们的另一种方式就是直接资助我们。前往 support.hiddenbrain.org，帮助我们制作更多这样的节目。再重复一遍，那是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·韦丹坦。我们很快再见。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。